[Music]  Parliament is discussing the latest EU  summit with a focus on the future post  brexit EU budget and the designation  process of the Commission president  cross-border tax evasion schemes should  be automatically reported to authorities  measures against service providers  specialised in avoiding taxation and  creating a special committee on  financial crimes are on the table  MEP s are looking at ways to improve the  monitoring of financing terrorism and to  share information on the European  counterterrorism intelligence platform  to protect B health and boost honey  consumption Parliament is pushing for  safe pesticides and more support for  beekeepers in its annual report  Parliament is looking at the stability  of the banking system in the eurozone  calling for action against risks in the  sector and encouraging non eurozone  States to join the banking union